i like that that was wichita state's
basketball team
celebrating making the cut for this
year's men's
ncaa tournament with everybody massed up
as you see even the celebrations look
different the tournament is being held
entirely in the
indianapolis area instead of across the
country like they usually do
and safety remains a huge huge concern
at least six tournament referees have
already been sent home
over a positive covet test cbs this
morning saturday co-host
daniel jacobson is covering the event
for cbs sports
and dana last year we know there was no
tournament because of covet but you can
tell these players are
psyched gail that is the best way to put
it i mean right here next to me this is
just a little bit of the march madness
that's waiting for them here in
indianapolis
the last team is set to arrive tomorrow
it's virginia the 2019
reigning champs they got held up because
of testing protocols
there is a strict coveted policy in
place for everyone from the teams to the
broadcasters which is why i'm here in my
lovely hotel room right now
the goal for the ncaa though to once
again
crown a college basketball champion
[Music]
as the tip-off to march madness inches
closer
teams are heading to america's heartland
for one of the most ambitious
national tournaments in collegiate
history for the national college
championship basketball finale
before last year's cancellation the ncaa
had crowned a basketball champion every
year
since 1939. while there was hope
and confidence that this could happen
there was also lingering doubt dan
gavitt senior vice president of
basketball for the ncaa
is in charge of tournament operations it
is a challenge to have
68 teams staying in four hotels
teams were required to have seven daily
negative tests
before they arrived in indianapolis and
then daily testing upon
their arrival we're requiring mask
wearing and physical distancing and
sanitation
during a normal year players coaches and
fans would spread out at regional sites
around the country
this year each of the 68 teams will play
in and around indianapolis players and
coaches will be isolated
each team will occupy its own floor of a
hotel
everyone will wear contact tracing
devices
but interacting with family members is
off limits
and fans will be allowed to watch games
in person but arenas will be limited to
just
25 percent capacity i mean we're at the
jw marriott so
there's been worse bubbles you know
michigan state hall of fame coach tom
izzo hasn't missed a tournament in 23
years
and understands the stress of the
isolation
you really don't leave your floor you
can't really go outside for a walk or
things like that so
right now it's just different but it's
not
it's not necessarily a bad difference
it's a unique year you know my parents
get to come still and even with
everything going on and
you know it's just really exciting for
me you know it's my mom and my dad talk
about it a lot you know and it means a
lot to my family
i've talked to a lot of coaches and
parents this week and
all have pointed to the sacrifice these
players have had to make just to get to
this point specifically
so much isolation and the mental toll
from it one father
he got choked up telling me he'd never
gone this long without hugging his son
look this is my sixth year doing
sidelines for the tournament i've
covered it in some way
for more than 20 years trust me the
appreciation and the emotion
they are heightened this year gail and
anthony i know for your teams it is
heightened as well good luck to them
yes yes we all understand but i like
what the coach just said it's different
but it's not necessarily a bad different
i'm just glad they figured out a way
that everybody can play i think that
that's a good thing
dana thank you and we'll be watching you
we'll be watching
you can catch all of the march madness
action right here on cbs and on our
partner network
starting later today